what is happening there
I'm a plane patroller person
uh oh an air traffic controller we're
watching guards of the Galaxy volume
three three official movie clips John
and I we are going to be seeing this
early next week we are very fortunate
blessed privileged deserving no one else
deserves to go but us so we are just
gonna ignore everyone else that we see
at this event really quick got an
important announcement I wanted to make
to you all if you recall a couple months
ago John campia and Christian harloff
and myself we did a live event at
Flappers comedy in Burbank uh in honor
of Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania to
be sold out really fast and it was one
of the most memorable nights of my
entire YouTube career I was a bit
nervous beforehand but it ended up just
being like an absolute blast again and
interact with everyone during and after
the show was magical to me so we thought
we'd do it again for Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. so Sunday May 7th 5 PM
Pacific Standard time we were returning
to Flappers we are going to be doing
another show there talking Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 spoilers but also you
know keep it like an open conversation
open q and a and then of course get a
talk with everyone after the show as
well and this time around if you're not
able to attend in person although that
would be the ideal way we're gonna have
pay-per-view links as well would love to
have you attend and then John will be
there I'll be there I already have my
ticket do you I do
go to the Pay-Per-View
all right so I just dropped all three
Clips in a final cut and then I hit
export now we're gonna see what they're
like
I miss you
so much
and maybe
maybe if you open yourself up to it
there's a possibility I don't think so
Quinn
oh no I will
what I'm trying to say Peter you know
this is an open line right what we're
listening to everything you're saying
and it is painful and you're just
telling me now we were hoping I would
stop on its own but I switched it over
to private what color button did you
push blue for the blue suit oh no blue
was the Open Line for everyone orange is
for blue what black is for orange yellow
is for greens
no yellow is for yellow green is for red
red is for green I don't think so try it
though
hello
sorry about this please we're here to
save the life of our friend that is all
Drax paid her to help us get in and get
out you think that mean oh I'm gonna
help you do it in a way that no one
knows it's happening but no what she
means is I'm gonna shoot people threaten
people's lives
and I know you're probably asking why
would I trust her oh that suits
the answer is
we used to be in love yeah she was my
girlfriend only she doesn't remember it
because it wasn't her because her dad
threw off a magic cliff and she died and
then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe
and she came back he took a
responsibility sure
final in the past they did not her why
was it the magic Cliff I don't know
that's some freaking infinity stone
scientist
that's a dumbass worth dude who met a
girl fell in love
that girl died
and then came back a total dick
you left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
that's a girl from The Suicide Squad
Drax still here with rockets
they're coming for us I want a clump no
mantis watch Drax Groot
you know what to do with these swole
Brute
yeah that group technology looks so good
yeah
push down on it
looks like you're pushing the keyhole
the what there's a button under the
handle press that in
okay now what open the door
that is a stupid design there's gonna be
an ass bottom they are getting their
first MCU F5
if anybody could do it it was James Gunn
strong language oh my God and thematic
elements and some other things we let
James Gunn get away with it right so
many people are in jokes they let him
get yeah
am I completely blanking on an MCU movie
that had an F-bomb I feel like they've
done the fake out they've for sure done
the fake out they better not actually
play the bleep sound in the theater yeah
these aren't the spacesuits too in this
elevator scene they they like get
arrested again at some point they look
like prison jumpsuits they remind me of
the prison from the first movie I think
so they look like test subject suits oh
sure I feel like this woman whoever what
is her name Daniela melchior I think uh
yeah
uh yeah I feel like she's working for
high evolutionary and this is probably
going to a section of over a bunch of
test subjects are that would make some
sense oh man high evolutionary he's
gonna be fascinated by nebula I know as
well as obviously rocket but you know I
feel like the least amount of
speculation goes to what's going to be
nebula's payoff but I feel like you know
she has had such a painful Journey as a
an experiment and so to have this be the
high evolutionary movie I have to
imagine there will also be some heavy
payoffs and or upgrades Pokemon is
genetically modified too true true that
just in in less you know extreme way
than a much more professionally sexy way
yeah but you know someone out there is
all about that nebula so is this scene I
mean based out the fact that it is a car
because they're surrounded by other
alien creatures some people were
speculating that it's not Earth it's
just people think it's Earth because it
looks like Earth but the fact that
there's all these alien creatures but
the fact that it's a vehicle that you
know Peter's obviously aware of because
he's from Earth if he is going Earth
this might be his first time we're
seeing him return to Earth bringing it
full circle Peter comes home you see
this trajectory of the relationship
between quill and Gamora I don't think
they're gonna end up together no I still
don't believe they're gonna end up feel
like part of this journey is quill
actually learning to let her go yeah you
know because as much as people might
want them to like get together because
you know they do have great chemistry
they do have great romance this is not
the same woman this is not the same
person so acknowledge that because I
feel like so many people would be just
like grab a different Gamora and fix the
problem because directly kind of
confronts that notion yeah because in
that first clip with saying how he
misses her okay that's sweet he's trying
to like what's the word swooners uh oh
like yeah make her Swoon by wooing woo
her obviously she's rejecting his
advances now he's just taking out his
rejection on her yeah yeah he's becoming
bitter and petulant about it and then
that carries over into the elevator
scene we don't have a rocket in any of
these do we I don't think so we might
get a high evolutionary clip at some
point or a rocket clip but if that clip
comes out after we watch the movie then
we'll for sure react to tell you all the
context surroundings yeah don't you
worry guys
time stamps
Drax wasn't in the elevator with them so
I imagine they're trying to go save Drax
I'm 100 of instructs is gonna die one
thing that I kind of forgot about that
the movies don't I don't like really
keep addressing when we first meet Drex
to a big part of his character is the
fact that his his wife and daughter were
killed there's a line in there when they
all that that moment where they're like
look at us for a bunch of jackasses
standing there's a moment there where
Drax says basically saying that if he
dies he could be reunited with his wife
and daughter
I think they're going to bring It full
circle like right when I saw that scene
again I was like ah there you go yeah
they're gonna definitely kill off track
the guys had a death wish for a long
time I feel like Peter will ultimately
learn to let go of Gamora but I feel
like there will be some kind of touching
emotional resolve that acknowledges
everything that came before that pays
that love off still whatever else we
have going with rocket that just seems
like it's going to be like the
heart-wrenching core of the entire movie
man that grew technology God damn it is
really evolving yeah you know it does
look like a guy in a suit which like
props to them I mean this looks the most
like it could be a guy in a suit just
like plausibly given the dimensions but
if that's all CG like somebody got time
to work on that yeah I think another
thing too with nebula she seems much
more restrained this time around like
she's funny in a subtler way in these in
these two clips like she could have
easily just broken that door yes you
know at the end but you got to get that
classic door handle joke it's the most
classic super a classic joke but what it
was striking me is like oh nebula's like
really reserved in these last few Clips
like she's not as she's grown she's not
as like immediately destructive and she
seems to have more social cues now than
before and they're doing a lot of humor
just based off of her reactions immense
dead pannedness and to the look of that
new arm like is uh I wonder I've I've
seen one still emailed yeah yeah yeah
and I mean you know nanotech and and
that kind of technology is you know all
over the MCU but it's kind of a cool
looking thing and I imagine it'll turn
into like a versatile asset sure of some
variety sure
I am
sure about that assessment and I thank
you for your support yeah let me see no
you're theorizing I'm going sure sure
you were so like a sure being like
Assurance yeah like oh yeah that's a
maybe like a sure me often means a lot
of times the implication of a shirt is a
a maybe yes a leaning towards it yes as
long as it's not it's sounding like I'm
being facetious and going sure like
that's all I don't want but but yeah if
it's uh I'll say extra sure when I want
you to feel that much more supported all
right well ready to end this video cool
Chris Pratt yeah
let me talk way too cut out half the
video I probably will
[Laughter]
approach in 20 minutes if you were a
Roundup
it's time to go yep
[Music]